the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
I'm so once you have the batteries out
they go in the back camera a little
notch is there just makes watches on the
battery on the bottom of it match up
with the notches here and then just
slide it into place there should be a
push button on the larger battery make
sure that's on the bottom if that's on
the bottom it will match up with the
notches on the back and it should just
snap into place um I think it was the
other way yep and you just get kind of
fuel it out there you go tell us
there you guys are already on the tape
all right once you have the battery in
and there's this little wheel right here
if you could just push the green button
in on it and slide it to on and once
that happens you should be in tape mode
the green light should be at the very
top of the three choices all right now
you guys should all have cassettes tapes
to open the cassette or will you put the
senton you just see this little thing on
the bottom where it says open eject just
slide it forward and pull the cover open
and it will pop out automatically and
then you just have to put the cassette
in make sure that the cassette is face
up when you put it in yep just like oh
no sorry yep and then if you just push
that down it should go back in
automatically cool and then you can
close the
and if you push that down it will go in
automatically and then you can just
close this
everybody there sweet now on the actual
lens hood some of them might be mixed up
but it's either on your left or your
right side there's a little switch it
says closed and open if you could just
push that to open just so you can see
stuff when you turn the camera or look
through the viewfinder or the LCD screen
now there are two ways of doing this
right now I'm just going to run you
through the LCD screen so it's right
here on the left-hand side of the camera
if you can just open that up you can
also close this look through the
viewfinder there's something right
underneath the viewfinder called the
diopter so if you can see a blurry image
you can just push that to the side try
to sharpen it sometimes with the LCD
screens focus is hard to gauge so the
viewfinder sometimes is a better gauge
of whether and how things are in focus
so underneath the viewfinder again
there's this little if it looks blurry
just play with the switch until it
becomes clear again if you guys look at
the LCD panel when you open it up on the
bottom right there's a little button
called the P menu which stands for
personal menu the menu on this the
regular menu is pretty extensive and
there are a lot of things in there that
you don't really need or that you'll
never really use so if you just hit the
prima p menu now you'll have two pages
open up that you can scroll through and
what I've done is I consolidate the menu
into the most relevant choices that you
will probably run into when you're out
there shooting the top left is the
regular menu so if you ever want to like
get more like advanced and in depth into
what the camera can do the top left just
go through the menu choices there right
now it's pretty cursory as far as what
we're going to do so as you can see you
have the audio channel one level audio
too
level those buttons a lot of people they
make the volume which is really
compelling just a headphone volume so
sometimes people come the levels are too
low and it's like you have to go through
there's a little in camera case to fill
our adapter which allows you to hook up
better shotgun microphone so you get
better sound so those are the two audio
level channels that you're going to be
using or playing with instead of just
the volume that's why they're up there
the zebra which is right there audio
channel to level the zebra is helpful I
think you can set it at either a 70 or
100 and basically it tells you when
something is overexposed you'll see
little zebra sprite stripes on the
screen so if something's or you're
playing with exposure and you're worried
about whether or not like you've hit the
ceiling of what the camera can actually
record basically you want to explain i
re s about exposure and the aperture in
video its measured the exposures
measured in units called I re units
which stands for international radio
engineer engineer yeah it's basically a
standard that was created 50 years ago
that measures the brightness or the
exposure of an image and if you go past
100 i re units you're not going to
record anything it's that's basically
where you hit pure white and adding
light just gives you more white it's
just blown out so if you go into the
editing room and you try to bring some
detail back into that you can't because
there's nothing there yeah so the zebra
stripes tell you when you are either
approaching or exceeding that threshold
and if you guys want to just hit the
zebra button right now
kind of you know it's one of those
things with your public use just hit
zebra on the touchscreen and if you
notice there's three options there's off
70 and 100 what I would recommend is
when you use the zebra I wouldn't set it
to 100 because that's the absolute
threshold I mean that's it's the highest
you can go when you see zebras on 100
then you may want to lower your exposure
and if you hit that little button on the
bottom right of the screen the
turnaround button will get back to the
personal menu now after zebra there is
the white balance option white balance
is one of those things that you want to
make sure you do but after you set your
exposure after you framed up your image
after view focused you know but it is
important to do it's all about the color
temperature and if you don't want white
balance correctly your image could look
to you like have this really ugly tint
of blue or tins of orange or something
you want to make sure that the color
temperature is represented correctly
within your camera so and if you guys
look at the the right side of the camera
towards the front you'll see us a little
round button called the assign button
what I've done with all these cameras is
I've already programmed white balance
one push white balance to the assign
button so instead of having to go
through the menu options whatever you
want a white balance you can just press
the assign button and it will white
balance for you so it's just a little
shortcut that all the cameras should
should be able to
axis when you are white balancing
whatever you're going on a shoot try to
make sure you have a white piece of
paper that's probably the simplest way
to do it if you're working with somebody
just have them stand in from the camera
zoom so you you're filling the camera
the frame with about at least eighty
percent of the white paper press the
assign button there should be a blinking
should be a blinking symbol and once it
stops blinking you're properly white
balance so just to give you a little
more background on that basically what
you're doing when you hold up that piece
of paper is you're saying to the camera
okay camera this is white make this
white and whatever the kind of color of
light you have shiny on that paper
affects what actually you know what how
the paper is going to read to the camera
these fluorescent lights look very very
different compared to the daylight
outside and you know you can actually
see it in your eye our eyes are great at
adjusting but if you stare at the light
and you look down at the the exterior
you can see that it's a little blue so
you put the paper under whatever light
you're filming you frame it up and you
push that button which is saying okay
make that make that that image white now
and say all the colors are in the sensor
so that so that comes out white and then
all the other colors will be relatively
true and accurate because white can tell
it contains all the other colors it's a
conglomeration of all the other colors
like if you can represent white
accurately then all the other colors
will be represented accurately as well
so right next to white balance is spot
focus which is kind of nifty basically
if you hit spot focus just press it
you'll open up this little screen and if
you press something on your screen on
the touch screen it will focus that
object or that person so you may want to
like just if you guys notice on the back
of the camera on the right there is a
little lever which allows you to zoom in
and out
everybody what you may want to do is
just zoom in go a little is not too much
telephoto but zoom into something and
try the spot focus and see how it works
so if you just press something with the
spot focus enabled press something on
the screen and after a few seconds it
should drift into focus
still working
it's working for me
the best way to judge is if you zoom
into something so go telephoto for
something
yeah if you just wait a few seconds it
should kick in
okay if you see the zebra that means
that that's over-exposed it's not a huge
deal here because I mean it's not a
detail shot if it's something that you
want to read if you want to keep the
detail in something like whether it's a
person or an object if you see the zebra
you may want to bring the exposure down
just so you can keep that detail and it
will grow it record it accurately but
there's something like the edge of a
table it's not a big deal because
there's no real detail in it so you guys
I go back to the P menu and I'll try to
speed this up ok back to the P menu if
you scroll down to the second page I
will you'll see peaking histogram study
shot exposure level lever and spot meter
everybody with me sometimes with the LCD
screens it's really hard to gauge focus
so there's something called the peaking
function which is the top left at the
second screen you guys want to just hit
that you'll see this four options
there's off white red and yellow and
what peaking does and by the way you
can't have peaking and zebra at the same
time like they can't both be enabled at
the same time so what you probably want
to do is if you're going to be in the
same area set your exposure first with
the zebra make sure that nothing is
overexposed and if you want to use the
peaking go to that after but with these
LC jeans LCD screens where it's like
really hard to gauge focus you have the
option of surrounding people that are
objects that are in focus with the color
white like a white outline a red outline
or a yellow outline so anything that's
in focus you can choose one of those
options and the person or thing in focus
will be have a slight trace of white red
or yellow around them and again with
these screens whether or not sometimes
they're smudged or like the resolution
just isn't very good sometimes that's a
good option to have available
because like Chris was saying is some
things out of focus and you bring it
into the editing room and it's blown up
even bigger you can really tell that
something soft so peeking is one of
those things that you may want to pull
out from time to time just to make sure
that you're going to focus focus
sometimes you'll find and today is one
of those days when it's really really
bright out this screen may not be your
best option in terms of seeing the image
if you close the screen you can actually
look through the viewfinder and then you
you know your eye is shaped shadowed so
even in very very bright conditions you
can see pretty accurately what image
you're getting and that can be very
helpful especially for focus yeah
unfortunately you cannot use the
viewfinder and the screen at the same
time no you can't so after peaking
there's the histogram which is just it
measures your exposure levels like I
think to the left of the screen is your
black levels and to the right is your
highlights so if you really want to have
a nice balance in contrast to your frame
the histogram is is a good thing to have
open it's not it doesn't take up too
much space on the LCD screen but we can
talk about that more later on steady
shot whenever you're not using a tripod
make sure that steady shot is enabled
because it it overcompensates like if
your camera is going one way if it's a
little shaky with your work study shot
just overcompensates with the movement
of the frame so it just stays steadier
than if you didn't have it enabled so
exposure lever it's not really a big
deal spot meter a spot meter is kind of
like the post at the focus here is no
but what was the other one spot focus
yes it's like spot focus except it works
with exposure so if you guys want to hit
spot meter is this is good for like
interviews or anything with people
especially if like say there's somebody
sitting right in front of a window and
like you're getting all kinds of zebras
in the window because it's over exposed
but you want to make sure the person
sitting in front of the window is
properly exposed if you again just like
a spot focus if you hit that person or
whatever it is you want to make sure
it's properly exposed on the screen it
will adjust your exposure automatically
so it tries to maintain proper exposure
on whatever you touch on the screen and
again that's that's good new jam if you
ever need
as far as the basic functions that are
on the outside of the camera that are on
the shell there are two well actually
three ways to zoom to go from wide to
telephoto one is the ring but what I
would recommend to everybody is or
recommend everybody do is you see on the
left hand side of the camera at the
front right behind the ring show me
right above where it says focus there
are three options you can go all the way
to the front / zoom you can bring it
toward the middle for auto focus or if
you switch it all the way the back you
can have manual focus hold still please
it might be in white all right so if you
go all the way back i would recommend
keeping that on manual focus which is
all the way towards the back only have
one ring and you want to make sure that
that's freed up for focus because there
are already two ways to zoom on the LCD
screen itself on the left hand side of
the screen you'll see that there's a W
and a tee so if you want to zoom out you
hit the W and it's kind of slow if you
want to zoom in you hit the tee for
telephoto if that's too slow for you
there's also a snap zoom camera which is
lever right here can you say that one
more time for me which part what is the
snap soon the snap student was on the
back right of the camera and if the zoom
on the LCD goes a little too slowly for
you i would recommend the snap zoom
which is pressur pressure sensitive so
it doesn't mean that you can't control
your zoom it just means if you want the
option of going faster you have it so if
you guys want to play around with these
zoom on the back right again it's
labeled so W and T so w4y t4 telephoto
son just play around with that for a
second I'm zooming right now
so that way oh sure okay sure
so the top left now that it's set on
manual focus that switch you can now
focus with the focus ring so again the
best way to play around with focus is
use either the zoom tools on the LCD or
on the background of the camera and
maybe zoom into one of the chairs or
something that's one of the cases or
zooming fairly closely and just play
with the focus ring so you get a good
sense of how it works
I'm going to focus on your headphones
Brian focus those their excellence
I last thing is exposure if you guys
look toward the front of the camera on
the bottom on the left there is a lever
you move that up and down to control
exposure so again that's the app stop or
the aperture so to make the image
brighter for a darker once you guys play
around with that tell me if it's working
it's not working there's an easy fix
this is the exposure lever
is that working for everybody because
sometimes you have to press the button
next to it it's kind of quirky
this should also be a bar on the bottom
of the screen as you're exposing
is everybody comfortable with the the
basic functions of the camera and if
you're obviously you're going to gain a
lot of experience very quickly with kind
of how these things work so but a little
bit you know obviously at sea with some
of them don't worry too much oh that's
easy it's in the middie never had okay
it's in the menu so that's one of those
that let me turn my back on actually
that's in the main menu so if you hit
the P menu and on the top left the menu
I believe it's in camera set so if
camera said is already highlighted press
ok and scroll down and you should see
beep eventually I can hear that people
Oh actually it's in the toolbox
yeah you have to scroll down a while
keep going
oh you nope that's for the headphones
okay and beep is closed beep is there it
is so you can see that these menus are
very much no problem anything else
questions show me solutions yeah sure so
if you have somebody else with you I
mean you could probably do it yourself
hold a white sheet of paper in front of
your camera and make sure that your
frame is I'll be your model so again
what i would do is make sure that the
light that is hitting your subject if
the subject is me is also hitting the
paper which is soo min to the paper yep
make sure it fills at least eighty
percent of the frame your lighting just
the lighting yeah so once you've you
know this is this would be a difficult
revenge the light once the windows is
very new frame is filled with white
paper so you might it just you press the
assign button you'll see a blinking like
a flaw blinds were closed and it was all
fluorescence once you adjust for these
lights you would be fine where does once
that stops blinking you probably might
be darkness yeah exactly and if once you
go outside today to show you can take
much your hostel once you'll be is this
the one then you go to probably adjust
via as long as you slowly
Missy
stop blinking it's still blinking
right it should be ok
it shouldn't be blinking but the color
champ temperature looked to change so
seemed to change all right um now one
more quick thing before we head out you
want to talk about the tripod yeah so
we're going to do so now everybody has
tape in the camera right because once we
put the plates on the bottom of the
cameras it's going to be impossible to
take any tape out and put it in yeah
maybe I sapin one disadvantage with this
design is that that if you are shooting
with the tripod it's you have to take it
off the tripod in order to change tape
that's how they sort of compromise and
made a nice camera that's so small but
anyway these tripods are about twice the
weight of the camera and you know very
cumbersome so I know you'll want to not
use them and in some situations that's
okay but I also think it's very
important to know about them and get
used to using them because for a lot of
situations interviews kind of like sort
of elegant sort of architectural shot
Beauty shots it is important to to use
them and to know how to use them
anything that involves control yet as
much control as plum exactly if you're
not shooting something that's like a lot
of action or motion right so anyway
great so if you guys could just grab the
tripod bags that are right there into
the wall there is a plate on top and you
you want to release it from the head of
the tripod so there's a little lever on
the right hand side or this little match
hand latch and you just want to turn
that latch and then on the left hand
side there is a yellow button that you
want to press in and then your plate
should slide right off the top if you
push that up make sure that that's loose
it's this this way that's so that goes
on the bottom of the camera once that's
off you notice that they'll there's two
holes on the bottom of the camera make
sure that if you turn the plate over
you'll see there's a word lens and
there's an arrow just make sure that
arrow is pointing toward the front of
the camera and then tighten up the this
group I wish yes the best thing we use
is like the the flat side of a key or a
quarter and make sure that that screw is
really tight because that's basically if
you're tilting and panning that's what's
keeping your camera on the tripod and
you don't want it falling off so so the
whole purpose of this plate is basically
so that you can quickly release the
camera from the tripod and quickly put
it back on in case you want to go
handheld in the middle of a shoot and
then easily slide it back onto the
tripod and just one thing to note the
that's almost the number one thing that
happens when equipment gets checked in
and out is that people forget to take
the plate off the bottom of the camera
the plate stays with the tripod not with
the camera so you always have to
remember to unattach it and slide it
back onto the tripod when you return the
equipment now if you have the plate on
the bottom of the camera and it's the
screw is really tight on the bottom make
sure it's really tight again the flat
head of a key or a quarter would would
work very very and it looks like you're
all set if you just from the back I
think it may slide it back back into the
top of the try hot tripod head and then
tighten that screw on the right again or
the latch make sure it's really tight so
the camera again doesn't slide off
actually I so sorry but I tend to do I
tend to line that one up see that little
brass see and I like that on the left
side there should be a handle that you
can turn to adjust the fluidity of the
actual tripod head so if you want to
have a little more resistance and I can
play with that if you want a little less
resistance play with it and use it goes
on you slide it on from yeah so again
you push that in and slide it on let go
of that nope make sure that it's just
engaged exactly like that now let go of
the red one and now hook lock it with
that see so now it's nice and snug and
then if you want to take it off quickly
you know you always hold on to it so it
doesn't go anywhere right you just undo
that one push that button and it always
goes it goes on back to fry so comes off
that way was on that way yeah again what
these years just like I mean reducing
thanks yeah let's say this was but
whenever it's like unattended make sure
that this is all the way forward yeah so
it doesn't go anywhere but this is how
much fluidity also right here you can
adjust the fluidity to okay
sister
because this is like really like a basic
thing like the camera could easily fall
and I guess the last thing would be just
just balancing it yeah they're so light
did it it's but yeah you're right so
that so that it doesn't tilt forward or
backward um no I'm talking about like
making sure that's balanced like the
level level yeah the loan so there's a
little knob on the underneath if you
turn that you can loosen the actual head
from the legs and yeah just make sure
it's level there and then title over you
and whenever
and just make sure it's really tight
yeah it's probably best to hold the
camera when you're doing one thing you
could try to do is just nudge it with
your like a closed fist or something
that's to tilt it's this it's just how
much you tighten it so like you can
tighten it you don't want to like
tighten it so much that you would break
the tripod obviously but like this is
loose this is tighter then I think here
this is I think this is the pan friction
so you can give add friction by turning
that as well so you can both tilt and
pan at different rates of drag and you
can mimic as I said mimic a much heavier
camera like that camera
ok questions
any questions
that is for the the head itself I think
that's if you're going to be like taking
it apart you should be pushed forward
okay so let's take if everyone is kind
of at a comfortable place we'll take a
short break and I mean you're welcome to
stay here and keep playing around with a
camera or you can you know just relax
we'll come back in five or ten minutes
and I'll talk a little bit about the
assignment the exercise and then the
rest of the time will basically go out
and do a little bit I have eight
separate kinds of subjects types of
subjects that I want you to try to go to
film and if you've only from six of them
that's fine this is not you know
necessarily a graded exercise but these
are the kinds of things that that I
think you know it would be great female
intern is doing so film landscape or an
architectural view of an exterior of a
building so in other words an
environmental shot film an interior
space either static or moving panning
going through the space revealing the
space you know you can put a stata you
could go to the hall you can just be
creative you know explore environment
with a shine film a portrait of a person
and you know we're not doing audio now
we're not doing Sam we're not doing
interviews we're not worrying about that
yet but but create a nice portrait of a
person visually follow exciting and that
could be handheld it could be a pan it
could be both just move the camera and
figure out a motivation for moving the
camera remember what we talked about
that you know when you're moving the
camera you should be doing something for
that movie either literally follow a
person or some of the object you can
reveal something so move the camera so
it close up of something in other words
you know how Brian our camera person was
zooming in on Dave as he showed the
buttons fill in activity and and
illustrate something with the camera
probably in a close up like that but if
you find some other way to do it or some
other other shot that tells that kind of
story that's my to think about a way to
employ a foreground in your background
element so a person the photograph
something in the background to people
whatever you might want to do and reveal
something with a camera that's kind of
this effectively the same as the move
the camera exercise again you don't have
to come back with with eight you know
eight shots here reveal something with
the camera and then the last thing film
something that you think is a beautiful
energy create something that you know is
at least your attempt at making
something that's beautiful
could be a person could be an image
could be a landscape could be closed up
could be one of these other things but
but try to try to create something and
whatever you're panning it's good to
position your body where you'll be for
the last frame so if I'm walking that
way you probably want to position your
body you like here because that way
you're unwinding rather than like you're
constantly stumbling with your feet so
find out what your last frame is and try
to position yourself there like because
you're going to be uncoiling your body
rather than moving your feet so but
we'll try it a few times do you want to
try it once without me recording it and
just see how it goes you can practice
just tracking
oh yeah i mean the thing with the spot
showpiece is it takes a few seconds just
to adjust so it's you may want to try to
just manually focus every day when I
just try to focus as I get closer and
then worry about focus then but also
when you're panning when I get closer
you can pop I will tilt a little bit
just to try to keep like the same
composition shot try to go with a medium
shot it's going to be difficult so like
from here up but my question is because
you're gonna
it's going to focus on you or about if
you focus on you guys are walking yeah I
mean I think you may have to it may take
a couple seconds to readjust with motion
so it might be just for like a few
seconds but you can try that you're kind
of cool give it a shot and you may want
to just adjust the drag on this a little
bit because right now it's pretty tight
just give me a sign
what's up I was so bored what a frame
okay I mean what you could do is try to
worry about thing in time like worry
about the frankly if we try to keep me
in a medium shot and then like stuff
like focus that that'll take time to
juggle all things at once so maybe just
worry about tracking my motion and
keeping me in a medium shot from the
waist up so you're gonna write I'm so
you're going to have to adjust like sure
the focal length at some point just to
keep me a medium shot so let's try that
by visiting told up for the lovely me
zooming in and up also you're probably
around resume out a little bit when I
get closer turn
panty ok and a little bit of a tilt two
right do you guys want to try some of
the other shots on the list I try one
more time my first attempt yeah yeah you
doing the same thing just give me out of
the ok side are you ready and when
you're focusing on a person try to zoom
in all the way and look for like
features on the person's face that are
really is think tiff those are the best
places to focus but I mean you're gonna
be out of focus at some point anyway so
yeah I mean this is a great place to I
think I was over across the street
that's just the hallway definitely a lot
more pleasing is like ice cream just
make sure you're balanced level
I feel like this like
but then i thought it's not really
you know well these are just exercises
at this point
just fill the
with something like
and make sure that whatever you're
filming the frame with is going to be in
your main light source under your name I
suppose
so you get plenty of ways to choose
it's mostly waiting just remember what
he was saying about asymmetry friend
asymmetrical
I just think they want to work on
exposure to you see you have the
histogram up all those levels right
there that's all your black level you
have hardly anything in the highlights
the right of it would be highlight so if
you want a nice contrast try to balance
it out a little bit so it's spread out
mr. ground yeah
when you're panning try to figure out
where you're in shortly
and stay in that shot so let's just
telling you like so instead of shuffling
your feet just unwinding your body into
its natural place of rest
so you're unwinding your body rather
than doing this and it's like all
jittery I'm staggered so try to figure
out what your last frame with a and then
even if you know you might want to
adjust the handle whatever is more
comfortable but just unwind your body
rather than like shuffle with you eat
and you'll get a much smoother
that's good question is what we did
exterior interior portion person really
what is that like
yeah it's just a finding a person
placing an ad recently interestingly I
would do the commuter shot
play around with like a focal length
that good there like a wide shot a close
of the Sabres with that this one for
negative space
if you have the person looking at
something to make sure that whenever
they're looking for we're looking at
like the negative spaces
so it doesn't look like they're looking
off frame so yeah I justified it through
thurs try to keep the eyes somewhere in
that top third that cross line